c'est moins 18 là est-ce que tu kiffes
toujours autant ouais moi j'ai pris un
peu de poids corporel j'ai vraiment mal
à la jambe s'il n'a pas montré solide il
est très beau show alors de quelle
origine et kenji
ce catalan quel âge à kenji la 24 ans 22
ans à quelle saison de the voice a fait
participer la 7 6 3 dans quelle équipe
encore quelle équipe
gare aux chenilles cas on a chacun truc
quand un dernier hommage parce que ça en
course
mon double optique que tu avais tout
allait mieux alors partir toujours très
bientôt
[Musique]
pour moi c'était arrive un peu le sens
pas comme ça voilà voilà avec un manège
de l'est
laissez moi tranquille
[Musique]
elles étaient plus de sous dans le micro
dans son jus béria j'entends tout
retrait mais tous leurs faits cette
intégration permet sur la vie de manière
violente douleur parce que j'ai peu de
vrai baiser mettez-moi tombeur de
kechida proposé parce que ce soir
bon ben ok
[Musique]
bon bon bon
c'est kevin sommer
bondé
et moi dix mots ont déjà permis
[Musique]
normalement
j'adore ayé dans blood of use
qu'est-ce que tu es venu chercher non je
rigole et on va faire
pamart mais quand ya pas deux
les personnes
en direct avec la sécurité
passé le marron et le noir et le rouge
[Musique]